my guest today is uh bart sabrolin you
may uh remember him as the time where he
approached uh uh buzz uh aldrin and he
asked him to put his hands on the bible
to swear as if they had landed on the
moon he went around talking to a lot of
people i think there was even a
documentary about it and then buzz
aldrin got upset and punched the man if
you've ever seen that clip that's the
individual i'm interviewing today he
just recently wrote a book
called moon man the true story of a
filmmaker on the cia
hit list he was also the infamous man
uh behind the i'm sorry the show the man
behind the infamous
funny things happen on the way to the
moon he does not believe we landed on
the moon he thinks it's a hoax and a lot
of other things are hoax we're going to
see if we can figure this thing out by
the end of today's interview having said
that bart thank you so much for being a
guest on vitamin
[Music]
so bart
years have passed
articles videos many people powerful
people have come out and said bart you
have no clue what you're talking about
tell us why
you were so convinced that the moon
landing was a hoax and what gave you
this idea that it was a hoax
well i grew up as the biggest supporter
of the moon landings my dad was in the
air force he was an officer
he got a packet at the time of the
alleged moon landings of publicity 9x12
color pictures i had them up on my wall
for 10 years saw them every day from the
age of four to 14. which is
3650 times and then
i saw a television show with this
gentleman by the name of william casey
on it he worked as a contractor for
rocketdyne during the apollo program for
six years he had very high security
clearances because he would edit
communications going from the top
generals back and forth to correct their
grammar and everything so they wouldn't
look immature and so he saw a classified
memo from von braun
who said the odds of going to the moon
successfully on the first attempt with
1960s technology was a one in ten
thousand chance
and so he saw all these departments
being shuffled around all the time just
as soon as somebody
got their full understanding of what
they were doing they would shuffle
everybody around they were doing
departmentalization
so no one could see the full picture
that the equipment certainly couldn't do
it i mean here's the simplest proof it's
simply logical
what they're claiming is that they went
a thousand times farther than they can
send astronauts today
50 years ago on the first attempt with
one millionth the computing power of a
cell phone i mean when they flew across
the atlantic for the first time a few
years later hundreds of aircraft and
thousands of aircraft were flying across
the atlantic when they went to the north
pole and south pole here on earth they
never made it the first attempt it took
multiple times
and there's never been a technological
achievement that no one could repeat 50
years later it's like me telling you
50 years ago toyota made a car that
could go 50 000 miles on a gallon of
gasoline and yet today five decades
later the best car can only go 50 miles
per gallon or 1 000 the distance you
would laugh and say the original claim
is preposterous and so here we are 50
years later and now the farthest they
can send an astronaut to the moon is one
thousandth the distance that they claim
to have done on their first attempt 50
years ago with less computing power than
a cell phone one millionth of the
computing power it just doesn't add up
it's the only technological achievement
that could not be repeated 50 years
later it's never happened it's also the
only time that they deliberately
destroyed a technology
i mean the b-52 is 70 years old and
there's still 200 of them in service and
yet they admit they destroyed all the
apollo equipment
and they're claiming they have to go
back to the moon and recreate it from
scratch they destroyed all the original
videotapes all the original blueprints
you would never do that if you really
went you would only do that if there was
a fraud and you were trying to cover
your tracks
so
i started looking into it at a 14 year
old thinking hey you know maybe this
guy's right i was open-minded 14 year
old and then 10 years later i'd become a
filmmaker
and i was editing
for the filmmaker who had produced the
show i saw 10 years earlier i said you
remember that guy in your show said we
didn't go to the moon no call the san
francisco production office i did they
said hey look if you called one or two
days later we wouldn't be able to tell
you because we're deleting all
ten-year-old archives so i called up the
guy he said hey you know you're a
filmmaker you should do a film about
this i took off about six months i found
out that two of the three astronauts on
the first mission
never give interviews i found out that
the administrator of nasa resigned days
before the first mission it's kind of
strange before you're putting this big
feather in your cat i found out that the
soviets had launched the first satellite
the first animal the first man the first
woman the first spacecraft the first of
two spacecrafts at the same time and
they spent 500 hours in space for every
100 hours in space and they never went
to the moon
and then i look at these shadows you
know i'm a filmmaker my job is to make
fake scenes look real and i can tell you
from showing you one simple photograph
that that the moon landings are shot
with electrical lighting i mean if you
go out in sunlight i can share my screen
if you want shadows always run parallel
you and a friend go out on a sunny day
and you'll see your shadows will never
intersect but in some of the moon
pictures
do you have the pictures to show us to
explain what you mean by it yeah take
the lead let's see what you have let's
let's uh
and folks if you're watching this right
now put a thumbs up if you
believe moon landing happened put a
thumbs down if you don't believe
it happened if the topic interests you
smash that subscribe button but uh bart
show us what you mean by this lighting
so here is a picture that i took in
sunlight you'll see that the shadows
because the sun is about a thousand
times bigger in diameter than the earth
that it casts shadows in the same
direction over an entire continent right
here's a picture that at nasa claims was
taken on the moon
okay
here you see the shadows
are
from an object about five feet apart
from one another here's the astronaut
shadow going at 12 o'clock here's the
shadow of a rock about five feet away
it's going at nine o'clock
i mean this is one this is all the proof
that you need that the moon landings are
fake my job as a filmmaker is to make
fake scenes look real
i use electrical lighting all of the
time and when i looked at those pictures
uh
10 years after i had heard bill casey on
television for the first time when i was
a professional filmmaker i said these
things are guaranteed 100 percent shot
in electrical lining i mean there it is
right here this is all the proof that
you need that we didn't go to the moon
and then in the course of making a funny
thing happened on the way to the moon we
found classified footage of them faking
part of the photography right in front
of your eyes i can share that now or
share that in the future uh go to us
show it to us you're on a roll right now
let's see it okay you just messed up
with our head today but go ahead you're
on a roll
okay well here is um
here's what i what i popped in this tape
and what was on the label of the tape
and what was
uh actually on the tape
of course this is this is in a
copyrighted film from me a funny thing
happened on the way to the moon
i popped in this tape and researching my
film
and it said do not show to the public
okay mind you i had asked him
for all the footage from just the first
mission figuring if they faked it there
are more they were more likely to have
made a mistake the first time they faked
it so i pop in this tape it says do not
show to the public
right and then i'm going to cue up the
next shot of it here
and then i see this particular shot here
of what is allegedly
the blue earth floating in space because
at this point in the mission they're
supposed to be 130 000 miles away from
the earth
and
this is allegedly with the camera up
against their window shooting the earth
far away which it's not
they were on the rocket but they never
left earth orbit and what a surprise
here we are 50 years later and they
still cannot send an astronaut beyond
earth orbit isn't that amazing i mean
good question when they were doing this
were you following the whole thing from
the day they left to the day they landed
on the moon or no
well i was only four years old at the
time i investigated this 30 years after
the fact okay so if you investigated
here's a question for you so when they
left this this is a uh
when they left to go land on the moon
from the day they left earth
when did they land on the moon how many
days did it take did they land it on the
moon
well they allegedly left on the 16th of
july 1969 and allegedly landed on the
moon four days later on july 20th this
was the only fake footage that the
astronauts faked themselves
now the basically i'd gotten the same
footage over and over again i asked for
unedited footage but i didn't get any
except by accident
bill casey thinks a whistleblower from
nasa sent me this footage intentionally
okay the so when i hit fast forward in
the machine i kept seeing this same shot
for the full hour which is kind of odd
why would i see this little shot here of
the earth floating in space for a full
hour because it was a special effect
shot that they were trying to perfect
so i i rewound the tape i hit play now
i'm going to put
the speaker up by my microphone so you
can take a little listen and i heard the
cia talking to the astronauts on the
tape take a listen
[Music]
okay so you just heard
nasa
talking to the astronauts hey the tv
picture looks great then there's a four
second delay
and then a third party the cia says talk
and then the astronauts answer hey the
tv picture looks great well they're
really in earth orbit so they heard them
right away if they had answered right
away it would give away the fact that
they're very close to the earth so they
had an earpiece in and basically they
were instructed not to answer nasa until
four seconds went by so first they were
asked the question
they counted off four seconds the cia
said
talk and then they started answering to
give the impression that they were far
away from the earth when in fact they
were still in earth orbit which is where
they stayed the entire time
and they claimed as you'll see from the
next clip or i could show that that talk
one more time if you want to hear it
who quickly prompts them with you can
edit this out if you want this from my
documentary armstrong speaks
[Music]
houston
says that the tv looks so great
so whoever's saying talk they're crystal
clear nasa has that radio eq the
astronauts have that radio eq but
whoever said talk
no
that's uh
cia they're very close so basically
they're trying to create a fake radio
now why are they doing that why what's
the motive to fake this okay because
they can't leave earth orbit and so they
have to show footage as if they've left
earth orbit okay so if you go to the
next clip here
right
this is of them claiming to be 130 000
miles away from the earth
we only have one window that
has a view of the earth and it's filled
up with the pd camera
okay he just said they only had one
window that faces the earth and it's
filled up with the tv camera right which
it would have to be if this is really
the earth floating in space then they
have to have the camera's lens
up against the window in order to shoot
this right here he is claiming first he
claimed that the lens of the camera is
up against the glass to shoot this this
is allegedly the earth floating in space
and this is space around it
but you'll see in a minute this is
really the circular window of the
spacecraft with a section of the earth
outside of it and the cameras pulled
back at the at the back of the
spacecraft with all the lights turned
off all of which they talked about
because they thought these private
conversations would be edited out so
let's take a listen of him claiming that
he's 130 000 miles away from the earth
or halfway to the moon
okay so right now he's claiming that
this is 130 000 miles out
that this is the earth floating in space
right
and
that um
he has the camera up against the windows
glass hold on let me try to put these
side by side okay
so here he is claiming on the left-hand
side
that this is the earth
floating in space and he also said that
the camera is up against the glass of
the window but look on the right hand
side
where the
recording they thought stopped but it
kept going they also say on the tape
that this is for playback later meaning
it's not live like they claim now take a
look at the image on the right hand side
instead
okay
so here you see the real position of the
camera this is the footage that we
uncovered that they said at the
beginning do not show to the public this
is proof that they're faking being
halfway to the moon here's a work light
inside of the spacecraft
they put a crescent piece of material
inside the window to make it look like
the terminator line between night and
day here they are removing part of that
those are the astronauts in front of the
window removing this is a one foot model
of the earth you see that
then we see the iris open up
and we see the real location of the
camera being at the back of the
spacecraft
you see that so they just faked they
just faked being halfway to the moon
see they this is really the window of
the spacecraft within earth orbit with
the bright earth shine coming through
but over here they claimed it was the
earth floating in space do you see that
we have the unedited version that's why
it said at the beginning of the film you
know do not show this to the public
right
and you know they're claiming that
they're 100 how'd you get this footage
well uh bill casey believes a
whistleblower from nasa sent it to us so
basically
three and a half years into the seven
year project of making a funny thing
happen on the way to the moon i
discovered this footage this footage of
the crew of apollo 11
faking being halfway to the moon now
why are they faking being halfway to the
moon because they cannot go halfway to
the moon
if they could really go we'd be seeing
the real earth out the window and they
wouldn't be faking a one-foot model of
it like they're doing now so if they're
faking being halfway to the moon it
means they cannot leave earth orbit and
what a surprise 50 years later they
cannot leave earth orbit it's largely
because of the radiation field
that starts at about a thousand miles up
that they would have to go through in
order to reach the moon that radiation
field is 25 000 miles thick and the only
time in history that someone has said to
have gone through it is the apollo
astronauts to the moon and back
and nasa's own kelly smith says that the
technology to go through that radiation
has yet to be invented i can show you a
clip from that if you'd like
all righty
we are headed 3 600 miles above earth
15 times higher from the planet of the
international space station
now what he's talking about is when they
send an unmanned probe into the middle
of this radiation field
as we get further away from earth we'll
pass through the van allen belts an area
of dangerous
radiation
radiation like this can harm the
guidance systems onboard computers or
other electronics on orion
naturally we have to pass through this
danger zone twice
once up
and once back
just like they did when they allegedly
went to the ryan has protection
shielding will be put to the test as the
vehicle cuts through the waves of
radiation but orion has protection
shielding will be put to the test as the
vehicle cuts through the waves of
radiation
shielding will be put to the test as the
vehicle cuts through the waves of
radiation
sensors aboard will record radiation
levels for scientists to study
we must solve these challenges before we
send people through this region of space
[Music]
so bart
okay so the point about this is you can
edit some of that out i didn't
basically he's saying we must solve
these challenges before we send people
through this region of space okay so
basically the guy just said that the
technology to go through the radiation
belt
has yet to be invented first he called
them dangerous radiation this was from
an unmanned probe i believe it was in
2016 the orion project okay they sent an
unmanned probe up there with two geiger
counters
they said it it's a dangerous radiation
and he says we must solve these
radiation challenges
before we send people through this
region of space meaning that technology
to send human beings to the radiation
field
has yet to be invented
you see that so i call up nasa i said
let me talk to this guy i'm a journalist
he said oh no he didn't talk to
journalists anymore since he made that
mistake and i said well send me these
geiger counter readings right of the of
the radiation belts and they said that's
classified
i said wait a minute you sent probes to
the sun to find out how much helium is
in the sun those measurements are just
nature they're not classified you sent
probes to jupiter to find out how much
hydrogen is in jupiter's atmosphere
that's just nature so why would the
amount of radiation in this radiation
belt surrounding earth why would those
measurements be classified because if
they release them it would prove that
they're deadly and they cannot go to the
moon so basically i found this footage
in making a funny thing happened on the
way to the moon
and it proves that they're basically
faking being halfway to the moon right
in front of your eyes and then we have
the audio of the cia telling them how to
do it because they're still in earth
orbit so if the radio signal goes up and
back from 250 miles up they'll answer
the question right away but that would
give away the fact that they're not 130
000 miles away as they claim because it
would take the radio signal
more time to go out and come back that's
why they had the earpiece in and they
counted off four seconds for them nasa
said the picture looks great 1001 2
3 4
talk and then he answers right after he
was prompted to duck first of all nasa
claimed there's only two people on their
channel that's a lie because there's the
third party prompting them to not speak
until four seconds go by and why would
they do that unless they're faking an
increased radio delay then we have nasa
about five years ago admit that the
technology to go through the radiation
belts has yet to be invented and no one
asks well then how do the apollo
astronauts go to the moon and back and
then you just you know when they made
the atomic bomb ten years later
it was like a hundred times more
powerful and another ten years later it
was a thousand times more powerful
this is the only time in world history
that technology has gone backwards if
they really went to the moon on the
first attempt with one millionth the
computing power of a cell phone they
would have been on mars 10 years later
they would have been in another solar
system by now and there'd be marge let
me ask you this let me ask you this so
okay
so just just for everybody are you are
you a flat earther yourself or no
no why would the earth be flat that's
that's a ruse to discredit people no i'm
just asking you so the audience know
this you don't believe the earth is flat
no not at all okay i mean when bill
casey was first on the oprah winfrey
show he was my original source at nasa
and he said they faked the moon landing
in order to discredit them they said oh
then you must believe that the earth is
flat also you know i mean come on it the
shape of the earth doesn't have anything
to do with the corruption let me
continue let me continue so so a few
things i'm going to take both sides of
the argument because this is how i get
to the truth so i'm going to give
arguments from both sides and then you
uh uh you know give your uh rebuttal to
it and we'll go from there when when he
said there's one in ten thousand chance
in 1969 technology they can land on the
moon one in ten thousand is not a big
number just so you know like in my mind
i don't go like you know because
winning the lottery say one in 6.8
billion whatever the number is that's
like ridiculous one in ten thousand you
know
back in 19 what is that paper done in
1903 the new york times said the chances
of man flying a plane will take a
hundred years of what you've you've read
the quote before which is like
mathematically impossible then nine
months later the wright brothers flew
plane so that one i would set that part
aside ten percent of americans today
believe
that men never landed on the moon so
this is not like that you're quoting uh
unfortunately that's a survey they
always quote when they do an article
about the people who who think the moon
landings are fake that that's from 22
years ago because the correct survey
today which they don't want to show is
one out of four people we already have
three out of four people
i'm sorry what do you have that for you
to say the correct one is one out of
four what's the source
oh it's there's been multiple sources on
that they the problem is they're quoting
an old one in order to diminish the
growing number of people who know that
the mean level you know what i'm saying
is what's the what's the updated one who
who is the what's the credit i don't
know you have to have to i have it
linked uh in the references of my book i
don't have that at hand at the moment
the the point is
that this is the first time that
technology has gone backwards in the
history of the world now it's impossible
it's impossible for technology to go
backwards how can we have 1 000
times greater we have 1 000 times
greater capability
this is to the moon 50 years ago it
doesn't make any sense i'm looking at 10
pc mag
is ten percent
uh yeah but they're they're quoting from
2019 they're quoting a gallup poll from
1999 they quote the same one
all the time 1999 the gallup poll was
six percent so 1999 if you can pull up
this thing so we can show it as well
while we're doing the editing in 1999 it
was six percent today it's ten percent
but still what i'm trying to say is ten
percent is a big number that's not a
small number ten percent is still a big
number to say ten percent believe this
never happened i there's some names that
always pop i think whoopi was on the
list steph curry was on those there's a
lot of people on the list of can you
tell me
big credible mathematicians doctors you
know of famous power politicians
presidents who don't believe this event
took place any major names that support
that bill clinton
on page 156 of his book my life
he tells a story about when he was
working with a carpenter back in 1969
he said uh hey you know to the carpenter
while they were building a house bill
clinton said to him hey in the moon
landing great the carpenter said i don't
believe them those television people can
make you think one thing when they're
really doing something else
and then he said after spending eight
years in washington
he came to believe that the old man was
ahead of his time meaning he also agreed
that the moon landings were fake it's
very simple there's no independent
eyewitnesses
no independent press coverage you know
what i mean it's like uh
they have a tv picture completely
controlled by the federal government and
three government employees of the of the
alleged greatest event in human history
i mean it's unbelievable that they're
claiming that they went a thousand times
farther than they can go today 50 years
ago with one millionth the computing
power that they have today it's a
preposterous claim if it wasn't for
people's emotional attachment to the
patriotism or they it becomes a religion
for people look how great science is
look how great we are
they would accept they would already
acknowledge it can you can you walk us
through what happened with the buzz
aldrin incident you were you were trying
to do a uh you were setting them up you
were speaking to a few different people
kind of walk us through what happened on
that day
well let me let me go back a little bit
to the to the progress here even though
we're kind of doing this out of order uh
basically when bill casey first
suggested that i do
a film about this right which is when i
was 24 years old it was about 30 years
ago i turned it down
because i saw the shadows intersecting i
saw the soviets were more advanced i saw
two of the three guys don't give
interviews uh the administrator resigns
they've by the way
you're the two guys that didn't give the
interviews i'm just curious
well michael collins and neil armstrong
they only
make very brief anniversary remarks
every you know you know 10th anniversary
or something like that buzz aldrin does
you know all the talking for them and i
find that kind of odd
if there were you know three people who
you know won a great sporting event and
and two of the three refused to ever
talk about it i would find that kind of
strange and if the administrator of that
sporting event resigned a few you know
uh weeks before the first mission or
first game of that series and there was
you know all this suggestion of fraud i
would find that suspicious i mean that
photograph of 90 degree shadows from
objects five feet apart it's electrical
lighting there's no way to duplicate
that in sunlight it's impossible
it means those pictures were taken here
on earth so but i'm telling you 30 years
ago
it scared me because i personally i have
kind of
a relentless personality and i also love
puzzles we were talking about games
before we got started i love games and
puzzles and i said to myself patrick i
said look if anyone could figure out
whether he went to the moon or not it
would probably be me
and i said you know it looks like
there's a good possibility that the
missions were fraudulent
and so i turned down the project i said
i want to have a wife and a family
someday why should i risk my life for
other people's mistakes so i turned down
the project and then another client of
mine a christian client said hey i'll
get one of your scripts uh mr filmmaker
to a famous hollywood producer if you do
me a favor i'm like sure they said read
the bible
so i started reading the bible june 5th
1989 the day the man stood in front of
the tanks in china
and it was a one-year bible divided into
365 reads and over the next five years i
read the bible five times from cover to
cover
and after that i realized you know there
is a god
there is good and evil
there is a judgment for how we live our
life
and i said to myself
if they didn't go to the moon
that's more profound than if they'd
actually gone think about this patrick
let's say they could go to the moon that
would have a certain level of
significance to mankind but if they
couldn't go they lied about it they
murdered people to keep it a secret
that's more profound than if they'd
actually gone and i said if they didn't
go this is important for mankind to know
otherwise we won't grow we won't learn
from our mistakes we will be stuck in
this corrupted world
so i called up bill i said i changed my
mind i decided to make the film anyway
well let me tell you these films cost
one million dollars and we were financed
by a board member of an aerospace
company who builds rockets from nasa he
knows from an engineering point of view
that we didn't go to the moon and he
said it was his patriotic duty to
finance these films to expose this fraud
okay that's who financed our movie a
board member of an aerospace company
building rockets for nasa who knows they
didn't go to the moon plus i had a guy
who worked there for six years who said
we didn't go to the moon but i still
said well
maybe we'll find out but when i found
that footage of them faking the shot of
being halfway to the moon with the cia
telling them how to do it i'm like oh my
gosh they really didn't go
and then it got you know even worse then
i found a source
okay
who was actually there at the time that
they filmed it now this is
what i'm releasing in moon man for the
very first time
he was personally there at a particular
united states base military base
and he stood beside president johnson
while they filmed the faking of apollo
june 1st 2nd and 3rd of 1968 we're going
to identify the code name for the apollo
project the military base where it was
filmed and a list of 15 people he was
the chief of security at this base and
he and they said only these 15 people
were allowed in to eyewitness this event
he had that list
and he gave it to me he confessed on his
deathbed
that he was there
and some of these people are still alive
today and then in the course of finding
this
you know footage this proof that we
didn't go to the moon
you know my phone calls were interrupted
i started being followed and at one
point i was literally kidnapped and
drugged by i presume the cia
to the point where
they were asking me questions i they
gave me true serum or something uh i
told them everything they wanted to know
i escaped i took my urine sample to a
lab
uh to prove that i had been drugged
illegally by this some exotic true serum
drug
i call back uh or actually a friend does
because i was trying to not
show if they were listening to my phone
conversations that where i had gone but
somehow they found out anyway when my
friend called the lab to get the results
they said well we had a problem i said
what was that problem they said well
there was a break-in over the weekend in
our lab
and they said the only thing stolen was
your urine sample
you know so all of this you know it
leads up to the second film astronauts
gone wild where i just had the thought
you know from tv shows growing up hey
why not ask somebody to swear on the
bible so we tracked down a lot of these
apollo astronauts and asked them to
swear on the bible that they walked on
the moon
most of them would not do it one of them
of course you know punched me one of us
one of them kicked me one of them
threatened to shoot me one of them
threatened to hit me and one of them
when i was in their house and they
literally physically kicked me from
behind when my back was turned right
after they said they're not a violent
person so they can't even lie
not live for five seconds
and the commotion we left a wireless
microphone on them do you have footage
of all this stuff do you have a yeah
it's it's an astronauts come on they
have it queued up right now if you want
to take a listen
i'd love to see it
and uh
basically um
let's see and you own this footage right
this is your phone yeah this is my
copyrighted film
and so basically we left a microphone on
this guy my camera guy and the commotion
of being threatened to be shot left the
camera rolling in the back of the car
and when they went back inside their
house with the doors closed
we heard their private conversations
and you know because these are high
quality microphones they work for quite
a distance and when the
production secretary who was
transcribing all the interviews with the
astronauts a month or so later she calls
me up very excited says bart bart do you
know what they're talking about in your
in their house privately you know when
you when the camera was still recording
i said no tell me she says they're
talking about calling the cia to have
you assassinated
i said yeah that's funny just no bart no
i'm serious i said yeah that's really
funny says no bart you're not listening
i'm being serious
and sure enough they're discussing
calling the cia to have me assassinated
i'll cue it up right now the question is
if they really went to the moon why
would they need to call the cia to have
a journalist who's completely wrong
assassinated
right so let me uh cue that up for you
here
i have it here
and here it is right here what do you
think eric george what do you think did
man land on the moon
i mean i can go without it
alrighty so here's a clip from
astronauts gone wild where you can hear
that
live microphone
and i'll play it for you now
[Music]
and there you have it you want to call
the cia and have him whacked
that's the voice of the astronaut and
his son talking inside their house which
astronaut collins or armstrong
that's edgar mitchell
that's edgar mitchell's voice
yeah
now the question is if i'm a silly
conspiracy theorist and i'm completely
wrong
you know then why would they have to
call the cia to have me assassinated
right
again if i'm a conspiracy theorist and
i'm completely wrong and it's silly why
would they have to call the cia to have
me assassinated unless i'm a real
investigative journalist uncovering a
genuine and outrageous government fraud
the same way with buzz aldrin okay if he
really walked on the moon me saying
otherwise it's like throwing a feather
at the guy why would someone become
violently angry for throwing a feather
at them but what it was like is like me
walking up to him in the company of his
wife and saying oh how's your mistress
she says hello
then he gets angry and that's exactly
what happened
i exposed his fraud i exposed this guy's
fraud and that's why they become so
violent because they're known you know
as heroes and that's you know the sad
state of our country they gave
congressional medals of honor they had
ticker tape parades for these guys right
and some people say when you just see
their expression from the press
conference they're convinced that they
didn't go to the moon because they look
like they're at a funeral
and so
this is what moon man is about not only
how and why we didn't go to the moon
not only about my crazy adventures of
being kidnapped and drug not only about
naming the military base where it was
filmed the dates the code name and a
list of 15 people who were there it's it
says look there's these people and their
apprentices are still at large running
our government
this is a dangerous one when did you get
that audio of edgar mitchell what he
said
uh that was in 2003
and what'd you do with that audio
well we put it in the film the follow-up
film called astronauts gone wild no did
you ever give that to the did you ever
approach anybody and and you know share
it with you know the cops or anybody to
say here's what was said or no
no however when my source
okay about
naming the base okay the code name for
the military base
and the list of 15 people who were there
at the time some of whom are still alive
today okay
and when i named all of this
i confirmed this with that person's
surviving family member
and when i did that
a couple of days later their house was
broken into
even though they had a security system
with cameras they were somehow disabled
somehow they knew their password
everything from their house
about their relatives involvement
in the military and at the space was
confiscated
and two or three days after that they
were visited by two government agents
who threatened them and their family
members with death if they ever spoke to
me again at that point i contacted the
white house press secretary i contacted
a united states senator on the select
intelligence committee and i contacted
the fbi near where this person lived to
give them protection i mean this is a
very serious thing you have to
understand ralph nader okay he wrote a
book in the 60s unsafe at any speed
right and the ceo of general motors
james roche admitted
that he had ralph nader followed by
former fbi agents right
simply to not spend money to put airbags
in cars
so if i am exposing the most horrendous
government fraud at least emotionally to
the public
i think they might keep up with me
and my sources
and that's why i was drugged that's why
this person's life was threatened that's
why all these things happen
i mean i'm sorry i really wish we went
to the moon our world would be a much
better place if people didn't have their
emotional attachment i mean it's it's
like a religion to people how dare you
say
that the great boon landings are fake
you know it's unbelievable we right now
we have 3 000 architects and engineers
right who will go on the record and risk
their lifelong reputations and say the
three buildings on 911 it's impossible
for them to come down with fires
especially the third one
and
yet twenty years later nothing is done
about it three quarters of the american
public says oswald did not kill kennedy
nothing is done about it we have john
mcnamara admitting that the gulf of
tolkien incident that led to over a
million people dying they completely
made that up never happened
and it's like
why is nothing being done we have
william benny who worked for the nsa for
30 years he says they listened to united
states president's phone calls supreme
court justice's phone calls senate and
congress members phone calls in order to
get dirt
to blackmail them to voting a particular
way
they admit it this is even on a couple
of mainstream media outlets they admit
this is a fact it's not a single
congressional hearing
done about it you would
well because the the evil people who run
the world and our government are so
entrenched they they own the fbi they
own the judges
this never happened what's the big deal
let's just say it never happened what is
the big deal about us proven that this
never happened
well if you go to chapter 11 of my book
moon man you see what the achilles heel
of all this is i agree with you okay
they fit going to the moon so what you
know
and if it weren't true what i'm about to
tell you i would agree with you okay but
the fact is
they murdered the crew of apollo 1
in order to go to the moon
apollo 1 was going to be the first crew
to walk on the moon
and they were murdered on january 27
1967 it's not my opinion it's the
opinion of the dead man's widow it's the
opinion of the dead man's son who is a
747 pilot
they have investigated it for decades
they are 100 percent convinced that that
fire that killed the man and two crew
members with him
the man who would have been the first
man to walk in the moon that that fire
was set deliberately
the basically gus grissom was the
commander he was the most beloved of all
the astronauts because of a mercury
problem he splashed down the explosive
bolts went off his spacecraft flooded he
admitted at the press conference he had
rolls of nickels in his pockets to give
to his son and school children to say
this nickel has been in outer space but
when he started sinking to the bottom of
the ocean with all that extra weight he
said you know maybe one such a great
idea the press corps laughed and then
somebody asked him they said
were you afraid
and he said patrick
of course i was afraid
and everybody loved him he's telling he
was the biggest critic of the apollo 1
program he wrote to a senator he wrote
to his congressman he wrote to every
general
saying they're not fixing anything a few
minutes before he was burned alive they
couldn't get a wired intercom to work
between two adjoining buildings he said
guys how are we going to go to the moon
in two years if we can't get an intercom
to work between two buildings he said i
can't hear you the intercom's not
working
you see and so he told his wife who i
interviewed extensively okay
that
the cia was all over the launch pad the
day before the fire
the cia went to his house and
confiscated all of his critical reports
he was filing with congress before they
even informed his widow that he was dead
they murdered the apollo 1 crew because
he would not cooperate in faking of the
moon landing so the reason why this is a
conspiracy obviously this has not been
validated or it's not been
this is a conspiracy you're saying that
they murdered the three
gus edward and roger well it's not a
theory this is this is the
valid lifelong opinion of betty and
scott grissom they have done thousands
of hours of investigation and i'm just
sharing their opinion
their opinion is the apollo one fire was
set deliberate okay right and they have
forensic evidence to back it up so
why would they burn alive why was the
cia there the day before the fire why
would they kill these three men
and then later fake the moon landing
because he wouldn't cooperate with it
that's why he was he was he conga lemon
the size of a grapefruit at the top of
the spacecraft a few days before he
burned alive said this thing is a lemon
he said we're 10 years away from going
to the moon not too
and he he complained thousands of times
you need to fix this business they never
fixed any of it because they knew they
were only going into earth orbit and
they had not yet informed the astronauts
same thing with baron
he was a whistleblower and he did a
report two reports for congress saying
you know this this is not going to the
moon by the end of the decade
and yet they claim they did something
you know they're claiming they need
15 years to return to the moon with five
decades better technology than when they
had an eight year goal to go to the moon
well before cell phones and microwave
ovens they could do it in eight years
now 50 years later it's going to take 15
years to go what's the argument they're
making today while we can't go back to
the moon why we haven't been back to the
moon what's the argument
what are they making but they're making
an argument what's their argument well
they said they destroyed all the
technology therefore they have to build
it all again well it only took him eight
years last time you don't understand i i
mean
reagan said they'd go back to the moon
in five years never happened then the
president after him clinton said they'd
go to the moon never happened george
bush senior said they'd return to the
moon and five years never happened
george bush jr said twice they'll go to
the moon in five years never happened
obama said we'd go to the moon in five
years never happened they said we're
gonna send an unmanned
probe the and they said they're going to
send an unmanned probe to orbit the moon
and that never happened they said that
in in
2016 by 2018 we'll have an unmanned
probe going around the moon that never
happened they can't even do that
trump did trump ever say we're going on
the moon we're gonna um i think he set
the goal of 2024
and they just said about i don't know
three or four months ago they can't do
that either
and china which is the most
industrialized nation on the planet
says they need 15 years
minimum in order to go to the moon so
how come they could do it
50 years ago in eight years and now with
five decades better better rocket and
computer technology they need twice the
time to go to the moon it's illogical
there's never been a technological
achievement that no one could repeat 50
years later never happened just crazy
with fraudulent loch ness monster
conspiracy or real
i have no idea who what does it matter
i'm curious a bigfoot is bad i mean you
know theoretically they're discovering i
think in the ocean about 10 new species
a day and they've been doing that for
the last 50 years so theoretically i
suppose there could be a you know a
theoretically prehistoric creature deep
down somewhere that's still alive that
people don't know about megalodon is
there megalodon or are you you believe
there's still a megalodon out there or
no i don't know what a megalodon is what
is it
you've never seen meg the movie
you've never seen meg listen bart what
are you doing you're missing out on some
great i'm writing books
you know movies out there
my kid my kids will tell you it's one of
the greatest movies of all time here's
another question for you i'm i'm a man
who believes in god but what do you say
to people that say let me get this
straight
you don't believe man landed on moon yet
you believe in a god you've never
personally physically met before what do
you say to that
i've said those people need to read two
books the first one is called privileged
planet and the second book is one cosmos
under god and they will see that
mathematically
the odds of there being life on earth or
anywhere in the universe is not likely
at all it's like winning the powerball
20 times in a row remember what the
government says is generally the exact
opposite of the truth they're trying to
tell you that there must be life
everywhere but these two books show you
there shouldn't even be life on earth
that it has to be by design there's no
other explanation for it things don't
make themselves cars don't make
themselves look at our body all the
departmentalized organs doing their job
the ear it's it's obviously design now
whether you can understand it or not
doesn't matter intellectuals get so
prideful they say well if we can't
comprehend it it must not be true well
my dog i can open the hood of my car and
say this is the alternator this is the
starter it will never understand a spark
plug but it doesn't mean that the engine
wasn't designed by an intelligence
higher than itself so the the fact is
logic says they didn't go to the moon
because
it doesn't make sense that they could go
a thousand times farther than they can
go today 50 years ago with one millionth
of the competing power cell phone that's
completely illogical it's the only time
in history that technology went
backwards it's the only time in history
that a technological claim couldn't be
repeated 50 years later you have an
audience of two people here outside of
unite
from the beginning of the interview to
today eric does he have have you at all
convinced that there's a possibility
that the landing never happened moon
landing never happened
no he hasn't changed your mind so you
think it did happen
i think it's like more likely than it
did
more likely that it did instead it
didn't this is a marine by the way
george you're you don't believe it ever
happened so we're 50 50 right now we're
50.
he also has not watched i i i i would
guess ask her ask the believer if he's
watched the funny thing happened on the
way to that you've seen the funny thing
happen george you've seen it before
george have you seen him before or no
he's never watched it the one who there
you go well four out of five people who
previously thought that the moon
landings reveal were real reverse their
opinion after watching a funny thing so
then how about we do this how about we
put the link to both the documentary and
your book
below for people to be able to go order
for themselves
all you got to do is put up sabrelle.com
they can order the book the book is
interactive the book has 15 video links
in it
and
basically i do a chapter so i say look
stop watch a funny thing happen on the
way to the moon so you know what i'm
talking about stop watch astronauts gone
wild stop watch nasa admit that
technology to leave earth orbit does not
yet exist
watch nasa admit that they destroyed the
technology i mean imagine bill gates
spending a hot 200 billion dollars to
build the first computer and when he was
done throwing all the hardware the
schematics all the records of it into
the fireplace it would never happen they
should have done that with the atomic
bomb but they didn't so why would they
if they really went to the moon and
spent 200 billion dollars in today's
dollars why would they throw that away
they would never do that but the fact
that they did is proof that they didn't
go because if they really went they
would never do it and if they were
covering up the fraud that's exactly
what they would do so there you go there
you go folks if you're uh uh
i'm actually really curious to know what
the commentary is gonna be if you if you
flipped anybody in the last 45 minutes
to an hour that we've been together but
regardless of it all i uh have more
information on this topic than i did
prior to coming on and uh interviewing
you and it's always a good thing we're
gonna put the link below to your website
where people can go and get all this
content
uh uh from your site having said that
bart thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
no problem appreciate you take care you
too bye bye
are you convinced that we land on the
moon or no has he
gotten you to flip to the other side
were you thinking that way anyways
curious you know if you thought yes the
moon landing is fake like you're
agreeing with them give it a thumbs up
if you disagree with them giving the
thumbs down and i got two other videos
for you to watch one of them is with uh
gentlemen i spoke that talk about space
as well michikaku fascinating interview
and there's another one i do with
stephen greer who talks about an
experience he had with aliens very
interesting doctor click here to watch
that as well take care everybody bye-bye